all right do this do the Starbucks one
yeah this is this is a personal favorite
today's drink has been recommended for a
while now it's brown sugar oat milk
shake and espresso oat milk
no shot man it's brown sugar oat milk
shake and espresso espresso we're not
even all the way through but I love it
because he's not trying to flex on
anybody no that's why this is so
endearing yeah yeah about to get my
third coffee big you've been
recommending me for a minute and just
the Bucks okay so I got my brown sugar
oatmeal damn what a cut what a cut let's
get that again
yeah that was crazy storytelling are we
going inside nope we are outside
you thought we're going inside Starbucks
I really want to see inside the store
reviewing the drink outside